a development that i noticed yesterday
just after we finished the show brett
favre
in a five minute or so interview with
tmz chiming in
on the patrick mahomes situation
and brett favre adding a voice to this
that i think
helps bring into sharper focus the
dilemma the nfl is facing now on one
hand
we see the indications that patrick
mahomes will be fine come sunday
that makes me a little uncomfortable
when you see shefty say the chiefs are
optimistic he's going to be good to go
the the chiefs should not be optimistic
pessimistic they should be knowistic
about this
the team's responsibility when someone
is in the concussion protocol is to have
no opinion at all so as to put no
pressure on anyone to do anything
because as brett favre noted what if
mahomes is cleared and he wakes up
friday with
a headache is he going to say something
to anyone no probably not
yeah but but but but if everything is
rolling toward he's going to play he's
going to play he's going to play it's
even more likely he's going to keep his
mouth shut
so i i think brett favre has a valuable
voice in this he played
almost all of his career in the days
before anyone cared about concussions
in the days before there was a protocol
in the days before an independent
neurologist decided whether or not and
when you could come back
321 straight games the vast majority of
which were played before the nfl woke up
to the dangers of head injuries this guy
played through concussions this guy had
concussions and came back and played in
the same game
he's telling patrick mahomes look one of
these days you're going to be in your
50s and you're going to have these
worries if you allow yourself to return
too quickly
from a head injury and that's what brett
favre carries around and you know the
the uproar chris over
over concussions that and sometimes i
think people overstate it
because it sells because it's it's
all these guys we don't talk about the
other sports that have concussion
problems just folks
right but here's what happens you have
a bunch of guys who played for years in
the nfl who are walking around
fearful that they have a time bomb in
their heads that's going to go off
when they least expect it that's what
brett favre is dealing with every day
that's what he doesn't want patrick
holmes or any of other players playing
today to deal with and
you know now that we've just kind of
gotten desensitized to the whole
concussion thing and
and and no one's retiring people are
still playing football hasn't changed
i still think that there's reason to
understand farv's message
and to be careful and to be cautious and
to make sure that
a player truly is ready to return when
he does return
i mean yeah i'm here i hear you there i
do i mean he's a legend come on this is
brett favre
they don't make them any tougher
especially at the quarterback position
you know all his consecutive game starts
it's it to me yeah it's more impressive
than a lot of these other quarterbacks
that have had these big starts with the
the physicality
in which brett favre played you know
brett favre took a lot of shots
that's the one thing patrick mahomes you
know
we're we're not used to seeing him get
hit and he really hasn't been hit
a lot during his career he's great that
way you've mentioned a lot whether it's
sliding in the pocket
fading away from blitzers however he's
done a very good job of never
having to take huge blows maybe to the
the way brett favre
had or did brett was a little bit more
of yeah i'm gonna stand in the pocket
and i'm gonna wait and okay you're gonna
hit me in the air hole
and i might see three people when i get
up but i'm going to throw a laser 40
yards down the middle of the field
that's going to change the game
and that was the style of play in which
he played
he he is he is the right voice in this
whole conversation there's no doubt
you know but of course you know he
brings up friday hey yeah
brett the guy's wired just like you yeah
he's if he wakes up friday with a
headache
he wants to be great just like you he
talks about it we talk about it
everybody talks about it
so that's not going to like change with
any really football players here going
in the future it's just how they're
wired
and then hey mike i hear you with like
the optimistic thing you're right
there it's a little slippery ice there
no doubt but i also think they're
reviewing a guy
who ran off the field had a funny
twitter comment after the game
has probably been moving around and
yelling and acting just like himself as
always
so they're optimistic because of that i
i don't think andy reid's trying to be a
jerk or put pressure on the situation
even though i hear your point and it
does in and around a bad way no doubt
about that
and i think one of far's points is that
when he played this just wasn't even a
consideration there was
never a structure there was never a
protocol
it was always you just play that's part
of football you get your bell rung
you you stay out there if you can or you
come out for a little bit they do the
ridiculous how many fingers everybody
knows the right answer is two
and then you get back into the game
that's how it was and i don't believe
that brett favre would have behaved any
differently
if he was playing today and in his 20s
that's one of the things and i'm not
going to go down the concussion
litigation rabbit hole but one of the
reasons why when people say
oh the players got screwed by this
settlement they could have gotten more
they should have taken it to trial
the one thing that would have doomed a
trial is when you put these guys on the
witness stand
and you put them under oath and you
start grilling them
if they are truthful and they would
ultimately have no choice to be when
being interrogated by a skilled and
trained lawyer in the art of
cross-examination
they eventually and inevitably will
admit that even if they knew
everything that they claimed was
withheld from them
they still would have played aggressive
they still would have done it they
wouldn't have changed a damn thing yeah
that was going to be fatal right to
thousands of concussion claims
and look i i folks you know me by now
i'm not gonna get on the horse and
ride into battle defending the nfl on
anything i'm skeptical that's what we're
here for we're not here
to to shake pom poms and be sycophants
there's another network you can find if
you're interested in that
we are here to to give you the truth and
to speak truth to the power that is the
national football league and the reality
is
in this case the nfl gave those players
via that huge concussion fund something
they would not have gotten
in trial they would have lost now the
nfl did it not for altruistic reasons
they did it because they didn't want the
truth to come out about what they knew
and when they knew it right there's
there's a weird sort of symbiosis here
that helps the players and helps the nfl
by keeping it all secret
but that that again my point is nobody
in the 60s 70s 80s 90s last decade or
today
is saying i'm not playing football now
that i know the risks
they're still playing no no way no way
and you know and a lot of them knew the
risk you could say what you want
you know i i lived with the guy who
played in the era uh
you know i he wasn't waking up in the
morning going you know what's gonna make
me feel better and extend my life
reggie white and jerome brown smushing
me this weekend
that'll that'll make me better it'll
probably make me healthier future in my
life come on
i didn't walk on the field and go man
you know ray lewis you know knocking me
seven yards to the right is probably
going to be a good thing for my health
today i'll
let me do that that'll be fun i mean we
all know what we signed up for
to a degree yeah okay maybe those a lot
of those old players didn't understand
the magnitude of that and i understand
they were cheated with that
definitely um the thing let me ask you
this yeah let me ask you a question
i i think i've probably asked you this
before you almost died
right playing in the next and i was
ready to stay in there and make excuses
and keep playing
well that's my point given everything
that you went through yeah would you
still do it again
yeah i would i just know i would if you
put me back in that moment as the same
person
or any like i just everything my
competitive desire
i wanted to be a great quarterback i
wanted to have a great career
we were all in two it was a big football
game
you know there was talk about benching
me and putting another guy in behind me
i just all those factors and the fact
that i wanted to play and win and be out
there with my teammates
there was just there was nothing you
were gonna do the thought crossed my
mind in the fourth quarter of the game
that man am i bleeding internally and i
just said yeah
screw it i'm going out to play again and
it didn't matter and that's just the way
it is
um and that's stupid or whatever it is
but it's just the way a lot of the
football players are wired ultimately
so yeah the stuff brett favre is saying
now is predictable given his perspective
given his experience given his age
it's not going to change anything when
it comes to whether or not patrick
mahomes wants to play or doesn't want to
play and
you know favre made a point that this
will be a test for the nfl's
cult but we're not gonna know
right if a mistake was made either way
i didn't love that comment by him that
part of it yeah well
but you know look and i've been trying
to get a little transparency get an idea
of who's going to make the final
decision here i think it's fair for us
to know
right although i don't want to have some
doctor flooded with
a bunch of chiefs fans this week or
bills fans as the case may be
bill's fan saying hey you know you're
better you better be careful yeah that's
your
you had to remember the hippocratic oath
dr brain
but uh but but at the same time
you know if you clear him and he looks
fine
it's not like he's going to be wobbly
out on the field like he was on sunday
he's fine now right i mean objectively
he's going to look
fine the question is what's going on
inside of the skull
sure and and even the best neurologist
in the world isn't going to know with
certainty so
i'll be stunned if he doesn't play green
um and
and and uh that's just the way it it's
been
that's the way it goes there was a time
when it felt like
if you got a concussion if you were
diagnosed you missed a week i think now
that pendulum has gone the other way
definitely and he's a quarterback too
whoever she is
well i'm going to clear it i just wonder
if him playing quarterback you know
too is going to help him out you know
it's different it
is a little bit of a look i know there
is
risk of course but there is less of risk
with a quarterback
you know we're seeing guys play to the
43 years old in the protection of the
quarterbacks and they're not
banging their head play after play after
play so at least if he does play and
there's
those worries it's not like it's a
middle linebacker or some star
defense end who you know is gonna have
to bang their head
40 and 50 times a game this is a little
different element too and and maybe that
dick
gets taken into account as well but
but if you've got a head coach who isn't
bashful
about telling his quarterback to take
off with the ball and when you have a
quarterback
who isn't bashful about taking off with
the ball do you restrict your offense
yeah
remember the play got injured on third
and one yeah he did he he ran to the
right and he did a little fake like he
was going to pitch it and then he went
down on earlier and and he got he got
tackled by mac wilson it's funny
somebody sent me a link there's a story
out there
mac wilson gave nick chubb a concussion
in practice with almost the same
type of tackle arm up around the neck
dragged down to the ground
this was back during training camp but
and mac wilson had to defend himself
then
for for injuring his teammate but you're
putting the guy into harm's way yeah
that's what you're doing so
will you curtail your offensive approach
knowing that patrick mahomes just had a
concussion that's going to be a real
challenge for the chiefs i i think so
i don't think you're going to see
patrick mahomes out in the edge doing
those type of things
now andy reid is famous for having these
awesome
little third in one fourth and one type
plays right i mean think about the super
bowl
he had guys doing the loopty loop and
the swirl around and the dipsy do
and travis kelsey playing wildcat
quarterback and do it he's just going to
come up with different ways
you're going to see it who knows this
week it might be tyree kill underneath
center running the option down the right
the
you know you just don't know he'll find
a way but i do think it's safe to say to
what you're saying
it won't be mahomes this week i i think
he'll be very careful with those type of
things
okay that said yeah if we accept that
right
the guy that that andy reid fired from
the eagles 10 years ago is defensive
coordinator sean mcdermott
how much of that does he factor into his
game planning
does he assume that mahomes isn't going
to run the ball
does that change how they deploy the 11
guys you got 11 guys you can deploy them
however you want yeah if you take away
one thing something else is going to be
open
are they going to strategically decide
to not worry about mahomes running
because they fear chiefs fear
another image another incident another
concussion for my homes
hey and it's all fair at this point sure
if if i'm the bills
how do i not factor in the possibility
that my homes won't run
so now i can release my 11 guys in other
directions
and not worry about my homes running i
mean this creates another level of this
4d chess match chris
it definitely does i don't think knowing
nfl coaches guys like mcdermott all that
he's not gonna take a chance he's gonna
practice even that
that third in one play that he got a
concussion last week because he'll
probably be like
man that's crazy andy reid he just threw
a fourth in one pass with a quarterback
that didn't play
i mean so who knows he might he might
still run the option with patrick
mahomes even though his you know brain
is on cloud nine to a degree or whatever
they're gonna be prepared for it they're
gonna be prepared for all things
uh because i just you know you they're
that's the nature
of a guy like sean mcdermott leslie
frazier
they go to bed at night thinking about
did i prepare my guys for every little
thing that possibly could happen and
i would imagine it's not going to change
their approach a whole lot
but yeah i'm not talking about
preparation i'm talking about strategic
deployment
in a way that invites patrick holmes to
run we're going to focus more on taking
away the underneath
passes on third and short and fourth and
short because we we don't think he's
going to run
we don't think andy reid's going to put
this guy in harm's way and that's the
balance because what did reid say
after the game as it relates to the
decision to go for it on fourth and
short
when the the chiefs were trying to milk
the clock he said there's no tomorrow
and that's true as it relates to this
season but for patrick holmes yeah
there's lots
and his family there there's lots of
tomorrows how do you strike that balance
and how much of brett favre's words
are taken to heart not by mahomes but by
read
right maybe andy reid was the intended
recipient of the message
if this guy's cleared to play and we
expect him to play don't take
risks with his brain is reid hearing
that
is read heeding that that's my real
point here chris
how much will we see a different chief's
offense
born of the fact that andy reid wants to
keep
patrick mahomes healthy not to play
football next week but 30 years from now
to play with his grandkids yeah i i to
me i don't think
anything's going to change other than
those type of plays
i don't think we're gonna see goal line
third and one runs you know short
yardage runs by him
on the edge but as far as hey let's
sprint him out and move the pocket
i don't think that's going to change you
know hey let's drop back and try to
throw
30 and 40 yard you know pass patterns
down the field
that's not going to change and honestly
mike i just have a hard time i don't
think about homes is going to change
you know you could figure out all you
want about about like right all the
quarterback design runs
that first third and nine if somebody
comes around the edge and he's going to
step
up and elaine presents itself and now
he's oh whoa i can run or throw and
whoop the guy went back to coverage i
got to run
he's going to run he's not going to
change again brett favre
he's just like you he wants to win he
wants to be great he's ultra competitive
that's the way he is
and that's that's you know going to be
the thing to watch for
where he's going to have to really
protect himself because guys of course
are going to be
it's my homes it's the afc championship
game you got to hit the quarterback like
you said last year during the afc
championship game and do those type of
things
and careful yeah i know and you know
don't drag me back and i know well and
you know hey defensive guys they're
they're crazy too oh oh yeah that's
right his heads hurt oh man oh i just
he was sliding huh i just i tried to
pull up i just hit him by accident
that's going to be something to watch
for the
mahomes mindset as it was revealed to me
when i spoke to him after one of the
wins this year and i'm scrambling to
remember which game it was he had a
couple of interceptions and then the
dolphins game i want to say
i think you may be right and and you
know he said
he changes nothing after he has an
interception or two
because when you start doing that that's
when you lose
so i think once he crosses that white
line on the field his mindset is i play
like i always play because once i start
thinking once i start restricting once i
start consciously limiting
the tools i have available to me that's
when you lose so
if he's cleared to play he's fully
cleared to play and maybe that makes him
more determined to be damn sure that
he's good to go
because he doesn't want to cross the
thick white line
unless he knows yeah with 100 certainty
that he can play the way that he always
does yeah it
could be it could be i i mean i would
think he knows that he's
there's no governor once he goes out
there to to what you're saying there's
there's not gonna be
he's not gonna change anything hey maybe
if he's in the open field
maybe he slides a step or two earlier
than he normally would have in a week
like this but i feel like that's about
the only adjustments that'll be made
and listen as much as we're talking
about his concussion and all those type
of things
i'm really intrigued to see where that
toe and foot is
that's going to be another thing for me
to watch for i just and again maybe he's
fine and told
you know i know they're trying to say
it's not an issue and the concussion is
more of an issue and all that
but i i gotta see that i am interested
in it this is a team that had a lot of
pass protection issues at the end of the
year his movement was key
to them winning games and that injury
just in my history around the league
playing everything like that
it's not something that just goes away
after a few days so i i
his mobility will be something to keep
an eye on on sunday afternoon
he was clearly hobbled he was clearly
bothered
and we don't know the concussion has
been the ultimate
diversion from this talk of
how swollen was the toe the next day how
much bigger is the cleat that he's got
to wear this week to jam his foot into
it because those things aren't exactly
the most comfortable
uh items of footwear to cram your your
feet and your toes into
so yeah that and the the injury reports
will come out
today for all four teams since all games
are on sunday this week so it's
wednesday thursday friday
we don't get a ton of information
they're far from perfect we'll know
whether he practices and if he doesn't
practice what his injuries are or if
he's limited what his injuries are and
it's going to say concussion and it's
going to say
toe but will he and that see if he
doesn't practice due to concussion
will he have been able to practice yeah
because of the time
so it's going to be i have a feeling
that he's not going to practice much
this week and that the label that will
be applied to him on
friday will be questionable and then
we'll find out on sunday
whether or not he plays and because they
don't travel
he'll be right up until 90 minutes
before kickoff if there is any doubt
about the toe
or the concussion hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports